also dass ein backflip beziehungsweise
ein rückwärtssalto so ziemlich das
größte überhaupt ist das zeug geben so
ziemlich klar sein aber irgendwann kommt
es bei jedem der punkt wo man sich
drängt sich aber was wenn ein rückpass
heute eigentlich komplett leicht ist was
wäre wenn man ihnen die alle anderen
coolen tat mir keine einfache lösbare
zwischenschritte gefallen könnte
was wäre denn wenn how to back clip in
andere minute wirklich funktionieren
schritt 1 sich mit dem rücken auf der
matte werfen
bekomme ich haye schritt 2 sich von der
masse runterrollen bekomme ich einen
schritt 3 beides hintereinander machen
klingt einfach und schritt 4
das geht denn ich echt viel zu leicht
aus ich meine wenn das funktioniert das
ist genial ich probiere es einfach mal
aus und schaue man wirklich so leicht
verrückte lernt man dieses video wird
unterstützt von blink ist da ich keine
1000 matten haben sowie der typ in der
anleitung und aktuell noch sommerferien
sind und ich deswegen in kleine
turnhalle reinkommen nämlich einen
stabilen höhenverstellbaren tisch
klatscht zwei matten drauf und alle
dahinter und schon kann es losgehen
ich probiere es einfach mal aus ja das
gab es auch cool ich gehe noch ein stück
höher
ich habe wirklich gar kein fahren wie
das jeweils funktionieren soll das ich
mich schon da drüber kippt ich glaube es
sei in dem video so leicht aus weil
derjenige der das gemacht hat halt schon
eine rückzahlung kann vor allem also
obwohl hängematte ist ich habe angst
haben wir sonst irgendwo ins nichts
fliegt also man muss erstmal das
vertrauen trägen sich einfach nach
hinten zu werfen wo man nicht sehen was
da ist ich traue mich nicht vollgas zu
geben
[Musik]
gut dann gehen wir noch höher
vielleicht hätte ich nicht machen sollen
bei 35 grad im schatten
die übung zahlt sich aus ich fühle mich
sicher springen mit viel schwung
abziehen meine knie sprungartig an und
lande dieser erste schritt klappt jetzt
also ungefähr so wie im tutorial nach
ein paar übungen die mich an das
kopfüber seinen gewöhnen sollen bruder
wo bin ich geht es einen schritt 2 der
landung
also ich wirklich jetzt recht hier eher
impulsarm trauen nach vorne da sehe ich
nicht was passiert und niedriger okay
ich gebe immer noch hinten
mein bauchgefühl und jede einzelne zelle
in meinem körper sagen wir bei dieser
übung absolut nein ich glaube eher dass
das ist eigentlich vorbei natürlich halt
raus sondern cool ich mache jetzt und
wenn ich mir dabei was brecht ich muss
mich blind darauf verlassen dass die
schwerkraft ihr ding macht und mich
fallen also das hat tatsächlich mehr
spaß gemacht als er hoch dürfen wenn ich
weg hatte ganze arbeit macht deshalb
chilliger landen auf zwei mal landen auf
einer matte
ich kann einfach ein backflip dann
landung ohne mathe sowohl das abspringen
als auch das land habe ich ungefähr
drauf weiter geht's ins trampolin lang
obwohl es so einfach klingt habe ich
mich in meinem ganzen leben noch nie
getraut einen backflip auf dem trampolin
zu machen die ganze zeit habe ich horror
bilder wie diese im hinterkopf wenn ihr
schwache nerven habt überspringt die
nächsten zehn sekunden unbedingt diese
angst muss sich jetzt auf einmal
überwinden okay jetzt mach ich denn
jetzt ok 3 2 1
nichts fast eine stunde schwinge ich im
trampolin auf und ab und rede mir ein
dass ich den sprung jetzt mitnehmen aber
das beste was ich nach einer ganzen
stunde vorzuzeigen habe ist dass
[Musik]
ladenschluss in 20 minuten
ich suche mir etwas was noch weicher ist
als ein trampolin und spring in der
luftkissen hier kann ich mich scheinbar
gar nicht verletzen und es klappt ich
will mich sicher genug um abzuspringen
und mich in den flug kopfüber zu begeben
zum ersten mal hat mein gehirn eine
grobe vorstellung was passiert wenn ich
mich an den punkt spiel gebe an dem es
kein zurück mehr gibt und die angst ist
[Musik]
er wirkte auf dem trampolin sitzt aber
bevor ich es auf dem harten boden
versuche muss ich den salto auf dem
trampolin auch aus dem stand ohne
schwung schaffen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe es nicht geschafft auch wenn
ich meinen körper und alle abläufe dazu
gebracht habe dass sie funktionieren
theoretisch es hätte klappen müssen aber
mein kopf hat es einfach nicht
zugelassen konnte ich einfach nicht dazu
überwinden obwohl ich wusste dass wenn
ich jetzt durchziehen kann ich es nur
schaffen aber es ging nicht habe es also
nicht hingekriegt an diesem tag zwischen
schülern und das ist an und für sich
nicht schlimm was ich schlimm ist dass
ich es nur nicht gekriegt habe wenn ich
einfach angst davor hätte ganz
vielleicht wie in diesem video oder zum
beispiel in diesem tutorial indem man
sie innerhalb von fünf minuten lernen
kann ist es scheinbar also doch nicht
aber ich werde meine angst auf jeden
fall besiegen lassen und werden auch im
zweiten teil machen indem ich es richtig
lernen auch wenn es ein bisschen länger
dauert zum beispiel mit so einer
anleitung hier in der das alles schön
säuberlich langsam nacheinander erklärt
wird mit viel übung und viel zeit wie
wäre das ohne angst zu leben vielleicht
wenn man sich trauen seinen traum zu
leben oder seinen schwarm endlich
anzusprechen oder vielleicht wird es
auch reichen um sich eine rückkehr zeit
zu trauern das buch lieber kopf wir
müssen reden beschäftigt sich damit wie
man sich von ängsten befreit und aufhört
ihr sklave zu sein bei blinkt ist dem
sponsor des heutigen videos gibt es
tausende ähnlicher bücher jemand
nebenbei anderen kann um jede einzelne
sekunde produktiv nutzen zu können oder
sie zu genießen eine besonderheit an
trinkt ist sind zusammenfassungen von
büchern die den kern also das wichtigste
des buches auf nur 15 minuten reduzieren
und mit anhören in doppelter
geschwindigkeit geht sogar doppelt so
schnell und wir nicht genug bekommt kann
nun auch das hörbuch in voller länge
anhören es gibt endlos viele bücher mit
wichtigen informationen zu den themen
unternehmertum wissenschaft
produktivität psychologie und viele mehr
und das auf deutsch und auf englisch und
jeden monat gesehen sich circa 40 neue
titel in 25 verschiedenen kategorien zu
sagt jetzt kostenlos siebenthal gelangen
so viel wissen auf wie ihr könnt auf
link fsd.de story und zwar bevor man
irgend ein abo abschließt und letzte
jetzt den grundstein für ein aufregendes
leben meine zuschauer erhalten 20
prozent rabatt auf das jahres-abo
flinkes premium ganz oben in der video
beschreibung trinkt ist punkt de /
pommery wenn ich schon vor meinen videos
bescheid wissen wollt was als nächstes
ein thema kommt folgt auf instagram der
pause schon vorab keine ausschnitte aus
videos und wenn ihr das nächste wie du
nicht verpassen möchte jetzt auch jetzt
mich gerne auf diesem kanal uns dann
sehen wir uns beim nächsten mal wieder
macht's gut
[Musik]